just a few things yes this will be
recorded So if you got to leave early I
mean it's Sunday morning
um that's fine it will be recorded I'll
be sending out the replay later uh today
and it'll be posted on our YouTube
channel
and another question I get uh about the
bar gaps indicator is it is for
ninjatrader eight it's not available yet
for gold charting or Sierra charts or
any other uh trading platform right now
it's for ninjatrader 8 okay so let's uh
let's jump into it real quick here and
take a look at what the bar gaps
indicator is all about all right um
so the bar gaps indicator right is I
over the years you know I've talked
about value gaps and it confused Traders
um because you know there's other
Concepts out there
um you know the the fair value Gap and
people would ask me if they're the same
they're they're not they're a value Gap
that I discuss in the order flow is
specific to actually taking apart the
value okay and looking at it on a bar by
bar basis the fair value gap which is
put forth by you know other people out
there is basically a price action setup
and and they will wrap order flow around
it they'll say oh this you have uh
selling imbalances coming in here
because this candle wick
on the first candle is not traded into
um you know it's not overlapped by the
third candle okay and same thing with
the first you know the green up candle
right you have this area of
bar one bar two bar three where the the
wick or the high of bar one
is
you know not overlapped into bar three
and it's just a price action thing right
and I know a lot of Traders will say oh
yeah you know you got institutional
order flow imbalance as well unless
you're really looking at a footprint
chart you don't know for certain if
there is
an imbalance in the market because you
know by the definition of what an
imbalance is is you have
um you know more directional trade in
One Direction than the opposite
direction by a certain percentage I mean
how can you I mean yeah is there selling
in this bar of course there is it's a
red candle right it's like don't insult
my intelligence I know they're selling
obviously the candle closed lower okay
just as on the green up candle right
yeah there is aggressive buying but does
that mean there's
buying there's an imbalance in the
market or just a big order going through
the market and again the logic for when
this pattern emerges is it signals a
rapid and significant rise or fall in
price leaving little time for the market
participants react in a sense right it
creates
a market imbalance that's what people
would have you believe however
a Trader can accurately claim there's a
market imbalance without looking at the
volume and the order flow right
otherwise you're just guessing right
you're just you're just saying oh okay
yeah I've got a selling imbalance coming
in here or I got a buying imbalance
coming in here
okay
what's your basis for well you know the
the bars they don't overlap huh okay
that that's your that's your basis
you know you're just taking a stab at it
it's just a price action
setup right and when you add
order flow to it right what you're
seeing on the footprint chart you know
it in my opinion that validates or
invalidates what you're looking at in
price action you know a lot of Traders
come to order flow because
you know I mean when I say come to order
flow I mean you know a volume footprint
chart looking at the volume right
because once they realize you know
they've been looking at naked
Candlestick charts so to speak that
you know they're missing out very
important information
okay now that's not to say that you know
you can't trade a naked Candlestick
chart right without looking at the
volume of course you can people do it I
just find me personally and you know
this is what I teach Traders is this
information is there it's available to
you why don't you use it okay it's
it's one of those things where you know
imagine right like
if you're cooking something
you know and would would you cook
something without knowing the
temperature of the oven
I mean you can try you know and you know
it you're going to keep taking it out
seeing if it tastes good or not but if
you have the information like you know
the temperature in your oven you're
going to use that right you're going to
use a timer so you know how long it's
been cooking for that's tools that are
available to you if you're cooking and
if you're trading you know volume what
you're seeing in the footprint chart is
something that's going to help you as a
Trader make better trading decisions
right so the bar gaps indicator takes
that price action setup uses puts order
flow around it to give you signals of
when you could be taking trades okay now
in today's little training session I'm
going to talk about a few things the
different ways to use the bar gaps
indicators we have trade signals levels
to trade from Market generated
information which is the support and
resistance
um I'm gonna go through the sort of the
settings of the bar gaps indicator I
might go through that first
okay it's
um you know because because when you're
talking about the trade signals Etc
um it might be better to discuss first
what uh you know what we're looking at
in terms of you know setting it up and
I'm going to talk about the markets and
chart types the time-based charts to
pick volume charts range-based charts
um e-minis you know currencies Metals
um energies commodities
now one thing to note right about the
bar gaps indicator and a lot of anything
that deals with order flow is you need
to have some movement in the chart
because trying to trade a market that's
not moving where it's trading you know
one two or three ticks you know
basically trading the bid offer or
sometimes just trading the bid or the
offer in a bar isn't enough movement
right you need moving and I'll get into
that
um shortly
okay so again
um
you know we just started so if you have
problems with the sound if you can't
hear just you know log out log back in I
did a soundtrack I know it's working and
again you know if you got problems and
you can't hear me just
log out log back in there will be a
replay of this
uh presentation later all right so let's
sort of go back and take a step through
here all right so first I'm going to
talk I guess I'll talk about sort of the
the indicator itself all right so let me
pull up a chart
and
sort of go through now the
our gaps indicator it will work on a
footprint chart here's my footprint
chart
it will work on a bar chart but to keep
it simple for today I'm going to keep it
on a bar chart hopefully everyone can
see the screen okay uh Victoria
[Music]
Toby says uh can't hear is anyone else
having problems with the sound I don't
think so we've got uh 100 people here
and only one person has complained about
the sound so
let me just ask him to log out and come
back in
okay all good here thanks Sams thanks
Simon everybody else
good good good
all right excellent excellent that's
what I like to see all right so the bar
gaps indicator all right
um
let me just get the chart here so it's
very simple easy to use okay so you just
got to find it in once you install it
it's just a simple add-on to uh Ninja
Trader right you just import it as you
would any other
um indicators you're going to just click
on it right make sure it shows up under
the configured part then the license
right you got to click enable and enter
your email
that you used uh or now you're going to
see Zone colors
type 1 type 2 green and red for type 1
buy and sell type 2 is a different
um I should call a different setup I
guess but it's based off the same just
looks at something a little bit
differently now type one is the most
common type two is less common then you
have opacity opacity is how dark the
zones are going to be 30. it's like 30
percent is
you know I I'm comfortable with 30 if
you want it darker you know you can you
could make it 50 70 make it 100 but if
you're looking at something like a
footprint chart
um you still want to be able to read
what's underneath
um the zone so 30 is nice then you'll
see parameters type 1 type 2 or you
could have both okay
I'm going to talk about this show signal
by default it's enabled pair up is just
it's like an extra
filter I guess describe it it's
something that's being paired up in the
order flow
um
but by default it's disabled it's not
something honestly that happens a lot
but it was just something that we
noticed and we just wanted to put it in
there then the sound file if you want to
use that
um you just enable that by default it's
enabled then you know you'd go in under
your
ninjatrader 8 files to put it in there
and it just uses sort of the default
sound file right alert 2. people
sometimes ask me you know how to create
it well if you want to create your own
sound file you know call it whatever
just drop it in the program files under
the ninjatrader8 sound
um
you know under your ninja Trader 8 bin
that's what's going to be on your
not under your your documents but under
like I don't know what you call it the
the C the C drive for the program files
you just drop it in there and name it
now
you know name it whatever just gotta
make sure you choose it down here inside
the indicator or what you could do is
you you have your sound file just delete
Alert 2 and change the name of your
sound file to alert to
um the other stuff you don't need to
mess around with data series is
obviously what you're looking at the
setup on bar close obviously the name
bar gaps indicator
maximum look back you don't need to
change that visuals just keep it all on
the same chart that's just where it's
going to plot on your chart now
buy and the plots right how it's going
to plot okay so you got type 1 type 2
traits okay and by default it's set to
five the Little Triangle up for buys
triangle down for cells okay but it's
set to five with if you want it a little
bit bigger I mean you can make it as big
as you want or as small as you want or
you could just disable the show signals
and it won't show these triangles but
for purposes of today's presentation
I'll make it a little bit bigger okay so
important thing is make sure
you enter your email under the license
and you click enable just enter in your
email and you don't have it clicked
enable right say I just do that
okay all right there's no signals right
I have to click I have to enter my email
and make sure I click that
little box that says enable
okay so you can see here right these
little triangles are the actual signals
right now
just really quick
it's a couple things you could do if you
don't want to see the signals
you just want to see the zones being
drawn out
you just disable that one that said show
signals okay now why would people want
to do that well
just turn it back on
there are people that like to trade
based off of what they're seeing in the
market right how a market reacts to a
certain level and you can see how the
market sort of comes back to these
levels
right literally to the tick you know
there there are Traders out there that
like to sort of buy at the edges or sell
at the edges of these levels
okay you see how the market literally
comes right back to the
tick here right 97 comes down to 96 and
three quarters before it rallies up just
like this one came right to the edge and
then it you know this is what 99 and a
quarter bounce all the way up to you
know two and a half right you see so
Zone being drawn out here
right you see it literally trades right
up to that bottom of that zone and then
sells off now the actual sell signal
doesn't come into a little bit later
because it's reading what's happening in
the order flow right as well to give you
you know it's telling you to get short
we're telling you to get long so there's
there's different ways that you can be
trading it now the difference here right
if we were to go look at
so I have both enabled right you could
just have type 1 enabled
okay
that's the red and green
type 2 cyan and magenta right that's
just type 2.
you can see there's less signals there's
one here there's one up here
um if there's any more a little bit
later but it's a little bit less common
there's a cell there okay so that's what
you gotta understand right it's not the
same amount of Trades
it's just type 2 is follow sort of
different criteria for having that yeah
um that's why there's there's less
signals
um
so again you could use one or the other
it doesn't really matter although I say
it doesn't matter but
you could use one two or both so
you know for some people maybe you want
to keep both on others you know you just
want to look at the most common one okay
um
so that's how you're going to trade
around it and again talking about these
zones
right if you have the signals turned off
how would you trade these zones okay
well me personally how I like to trade
these zones is I look for when all right
I have a Zone starting to be drawn out
and it's not traded back into to me
that's a sign of a market that's
potentially getting ready to move right
you can see here where we're sideways
we trade right back into it looks like
it's going to break right then you get
the little pop-up a little path down so
sort of coming down to the difference of
should I use zones or or should I not
use Zone should I just rely on signals
right if you just wanted to rely
on the signals
okay what you can do
is
there's two ways to do it right
basically to turn off the zones you just
change the opacity to zero right so I'm
going to enable the signals turn off the
opacity
to zero so I'm just seeing the cell
signals or the buy signals right so I
got cell here I've got the buys coming
in here and again a little back and
forth you know sideways action in here
you know chop right but again when
you're Trading
where's the best place to buy well after
a sell-off right after the market is
sold off down to you know a new low or
new swing low potentially you're going
to be looking to buy
right or if you're breaking out of an
area where the market has been going
sideways right like here
okay this Mark has been going sideways
how can you identify that you just look
at the chart or you don't need anything
fancy
you know you don't need to be trying to
sell here or buy here you're still in
your range
if you start trading above or below
that's where you look for the signals to
come in in here
right because the last thing you want to
do is try and get short here try and get
long here try and get long here try and
get short here
when here you got clear validation that
you're just breaking out that's a simple
technical analysis right you could use
order flow for that or you could just
look at your chart
okay this is I believe this is that area
right in here I've got this one set at I
should make those triangles a bit bigger
so it's easier to see
let me just uh change that here
uh I'll just make it 12.
so it's very easy to see I think I got
them both enabled
all right so okay both
okay so you see it's drawing you know
the nice thing about this indicator is
we programmed it in a way it doesn't
need tick replay to work okay so you can
see as we're breaking out of this area
this
sideways activity
all right now you're getting the signals
okay and if you want to use the zones
all right like down in here again
there's different ways you could use it
right you could you know look to buy
inside of a Zone
with a tight stop or Look to You Know
maybe just on the other side of it you
know in front
um
I'm not one of these people necessary
that says oh I've got a bearish Zone
being drawn here if it breaks to the
upside I'm going to get long I mean I
know guys that like to trade certain way
that way
um you know when they have support and
resistance because if this is resistance
and it's breaking down by definition
previous resistance is going to become
support okay but that's just you know it
depends on your trading Style
right I like to watch it when it sort of
comes back up if it's struggling to get
inside or get through it
you know that that's a sign to me
because I know right like at this area
right here
right I I have this little Zone being
drawn out
and I know that
you know you get this unfinished
business so to speak you know the
unfinished auctions I know the market
was bid at 01 offered inside of the zone
and it's not even trading in there okay
so you know to me that could be a sign
that this Market's going to react right
same thing here it trades right into the
zone
and then it starts a nice rally up from
that okay now
that sort of touches on the you know the
trade signals the levels to trade from
the market generated information you
know that that support and resistance
okay when it comes down into these zones
that's how you could use these zones
again it's up to you whether you want to
use
um
the zones or not use them right
the signals whether you want to use them
or not you could disable that or you
could turn off the zones or you could
use both the zones and the signal right
it's it's up to you if
you know let's turn these zones back on
right and I'll turn off the signals
and you know the next question I know
I'm going to get a lot of questions on
is you know what other types of chart
can you use it on well you could use it
on obviously this is a minute based
chart you could use it on tick based
charts volume based charge range-based
charts as long as there's movements okay
so for example if I was going to look at
a 10-year chart
like a one minute 10-year chart well I'm
not going to get any signals or you know
might get a Zone here and there but I'm
not getting any signals because it's
market right it's trading one tick well
it takes in half ticks but basically you
know the minimum tick from 17 and a half
up to 18. right that's not going to be
enough to and you're doing that most of
the day on a market like 10 years right
you'd want something that's going to
give you
um some movement right even on a range
based chart you're starting to see you
know a bit of movement as well again you
know 10 years
is it
just make this uh turn the signal on you
can sort of see where the buys and cells
are coming in right
you can see here right the cells the
buys sell buy sell and 10 years is not a
market that trades
a lot of movement period right because
it trades a lot of volume so it's a
slower moving Market if
you know they're on a different Market I
don't know soybeans okay soybeans that
you could look at a range based chart
you could look at a time-based chart
um at least here you're getting a bit of
movement right this is a four range
chart if
um you know if you wanted to look at
I don't know 50 or 100 tick right I'll
start with 50 tick and
beans right how does it look I don't
know
okay again 50 tick on the beans is
probably not enough movement because
you're getting a lot of action where
it's just one tick here one ticks on the
bars
you know earlier when you know there is
some bit of movement right you're
getting more and more signals
but if you were to go maybe to a
slightly higher
range or you know 100 tick okay this is
100 dicks so it's taking in more trades
you're seeing some you know more signals
that you can see how this Market came
right back up to this Zone here right up
to this Zone here
um you know Market sold off to where
where you have the Zone from earlier
here you got a zone right order this
Market it's sold off and it stopped
literally right here okay now got
through this Zone got a Zone from way
earlier literally came right down to
that level
right
you know so that's uh you know a 100
tick chart if you're on a time-based
chart in
foreign
Gremlins are out
but this is a tick based chart
you know if you're trading zones does
every zone is it going to hold no
I mean we wish they would
but again you know it can allow you that
trading just the zones by themselves can
allow you to have
um you know some
tighter stops
okay
you know markets like I don't know
that's what is beans take a look at gold
right this is gold from Friday okay you
got that one last Zone being drawn out
trades right to it there's your signal
and again if
you want to use the zones it just makes
things a little bit more visual if you
don't want to use it you just
change it opacity to zero
okay and you can see the the buy signals
coming in here
you know some small shorts small longs
and then late in the day there
you know that's gold
um
sorry coughing there you know Euro FX 6E
okay same thing
right right before that big move up
right the magenta and cyan all right
that's magenta that's cyan that's the
type one trades
um let me show you the difference here
so if you have just type one
that's just the green and red right the
greens and red type two it's just the
magenta
here here and cyan cyan cyan cyan cyan
magenta coming in there
um so I mean you keep both again if
you just want to see the zones
right or the coming in where a potential
area where a market can stop right in
here
right right over here
kind of stopped in here
you get the idea right
[Music]
um
of how did you just use the zones by
themselves okay let me just turn this
back on
foreign
again if you're interested in bonds you
can always trade you know regular bonds
again on a minute based chart
I'm not sure you're going to get enough
movement on
okay
the bond Futures right again you know
we're sort of an interest rate sensitive
Market the ultra bonds yeah
you know you're not getting enough
signals right just because it's just not
the
the Market's a little too tight on a one
minute chart
um
you know you can even
you know but there's a 15 minute chart
right there's a cell here it literally
came right back up to the area came
right back up to this area here and
again it's not just about every single
Gap that you know fair value Gap that's
taking place right you don't see any
gaps being drawn out here or signals
being drawn here it's ones that you know
when we add order flow to right because
you know here's
you know there's some in here on this
move up some on this move down
um you know you really want the ones
that where you're adding the order flow
in my opinion make it more effective if
you know 15 minute chart on e-minis I
don't know how it looks
okay
and you got this one zone from way
earlier and it really you know if you're
using zones you know as a Target you can
you can see right Market came right to
this level okay blew through this one
but there was no signal here yeah it got
a little through got a signal here you
see the market pulled right back to this
Zone just chewed through this this one
in here
um then you're getting these short
signals here this is a 15 minute chart
earlier right even here right you got
that cell signal zone coming in where
did the market come back to and sort of
hang around came right back into that
bigger zone now people are going to ask
me is a bigger Zone more important than
a smaller Zone well
I don't think so
you know a zone is a Zone
but
sometimes I like to think that if it's a
thicker Zone
it could run into you know to get
through a thicker Zone in my opinion is
takes a little bit more effort but just
because we get through the other side
right like the Zone here we got through
the other side and it just traded a
couple ticks up through and it came down
um you got this thin Zone here at you
know 13 and a quarter
right and expecting the market to come
down literally to the tick and then you
know after you sell off from the 60s
down to 13
um to stop right at that
one tick and then you know maybe
balances is asking a lot because there's
a lot of selling momentum as this Market
is dropping down
that you know it may not uh it may not
just hit that area and then bounce up
from
okay
uh let's just get back to
you know let's take a look at
you know some other markets here
and then Q
change it for 15 minutes because 15
minute mnq is going to look you know
this is very similar to
the e-minis
um honestly I'm in Q and human he's very
highly correlated
it's gonna be a little bit more volatile
obviously it's mnq
but you can see it's trying to Rally in
here then get that nice sell-off and
again you know sort of talking about
you know expecting a market to pull back
to a certain level
you know more volatile markets they
don't often come back strictly right to
a level and then you know turn around
and then make their move you know
something they'll tend to overshoot it
just as it did you know
here and here right because it's easy to
say when you got a big Zone oh yeah the
Zone held uh this Zone didn't hold well
this zone is only you know what is that
three ticks whereas this zone is you
know 82 down to 71. this this is 11
points where this is not even one point
right so to say oh this Zone failed well
it's a very tight Zone you know this one
is
bigger so it's got a higher chance of
holding okay but let's take a look at um
you know some other markets I know
there's a lot of guys I got here today
trading Commodities Commodities are
great markets they follow supply and
demand
um nicely this is wheat okay
you can see all right there's the open
it only rallies up
what does it come back down to right
down to this Zone before bouncing back
up okay this is a minute based chart but
you know with wheat you know you could
trade a tick base chart or even a volume
based chart you know people ask me what
do I prefer volume or tick I actually I
prefer tick over volume but um you know
that's just more of a personal choice
see we had this one zone being drawn out
here Market went up on the reopen on the
Us hours open it came right down to that
level shot up
shot up again
um that's a 100 I'm sorry what is that
50 tick again for some people maybe 50
tick is too fast
um you know 100 tick
looks like this this was again you're
gonna get these days where it's like
this yeah you got some small winners
then there's days like the day before
where you get the nice
you know 15 cent move
but that's how the markets are you can
only trade what the market uh gives you
you know that gas crude you know take a
look at net gas
uh where am I here I guess in G
okay this is what is this this is a 100
tick chart
okay yeah these levels holding I mean
you know you got a big Zone here
basically drawn out over several bars
did it hold I guess so but you know if
you're trading on a short term basis if
you're an intraday Trader I say rely
more on the signals than the zones I
mean you can you know try to pick off
levels with the zones like here this
would be a nice trade to have
right like this right here
you know you just drop in a Cell limit
Order In the Zone with a stop just on
the other side you're dropping a buy
here but there's gonna be times where
you
drop in a buy right in the middle of
this Zone
and then stops you out you got to be you
know if you're a Zone type Trader you
got to be willing to understand that
there's going to be you know some stop
outs but if you're trading in a Zone
you know it can give you a big move
right so there's there's different ways
to approach the market you know which
way is the best what depends on how
you're trading if you're more of a
longer term Trader you know
foreign
this is crude there's a 15-minute chart
on crude
right you see the zone now this is
another question people come up how come
there's like a Zone being drawn out but
there's no signal right no green arrow
up Arrow
for the zone is because
even though you got the zone
you know the order flow that's taking
place inside of that's causing the zone
what's also taking place because again
you know it it reads what's happening
after Zone you know after a gap is
appearing as well because it's one thing
to have the Gap you want to have some
water flow inside there but you want to
also need the complementary order flow
the order flow that's coming in after
that's been made okay and it just wasn't
any coming in here
right in here right in here it doesn't
come into
here this little Gap but you can see how
crude oh my gosh where are we trading
crude the 90 bucks better fill up the
tank but um you know 15 minute chart
right I mean we ran out of time on
Friday but it came right back up to this
Zone here I I don't know man I don't
know what's going on with this uh price
of gas price oil nowadays I think it's
gonna Skyrocket
um but it's just my own opinion
but you know nice moves down nice moves
up okay
so um I'm gonna spend some time now I'm
gonna take a look at some of these
questions
um
in here because there's a lot of
questions
okay Juan asks uh
just a question about the Gap and can
you show us some of this your indicator
in the one integrated into nt8
are they different
I don't know which one you're talking
about that's integrated into nt8
Quan so you'd have to
clear that up
um
the bar gaps indicator again is not a
footprint chart
it's reading the price action one which
you don't need to put print chart for
but two it's also reading
some of the order flow going to I'm not
going to get into what it's reading but
it's reading some of the order flowing
there okay
um GT had asked how does this worker how
does this indicator work together with
Delta scalper well it reads different
things
um
in the order flow okay so for example
right
if
uh well let's go back okay we'll go back
to the e-mini Chart right which I know
what a lot of you guys trade
and go back here let me just add on
make sure okay
again you can use this indicator with or
without tick replay okay
so you see tick replay is turned off but
if you're using an indicator that
requires tick replay like Delta scalper
yeah enable take replay so it'll work
with tick replay on or off and again if
you're using one that requires it like
Delta scalper
um just
keep it on here
now it's blue and red what I'm going to
do is I'm going to change this color
because I don't want to confuse signals
um
foreign
for a
cell
let's make it a purple okay so blue for
buys it's reading different things in
the order flow okay so well that's just
calculating here so you shouldn't get
the same signals will some signals
overlap potentially
let's just pull it in here for most of
the day
okay so Delta scalper coming in here I
think there was a signal that overlapped
in here
Delta scalpers the blue Buys in here
can I use Delta scalper here a couple
overlap coming in here
Delta scalper
uh
a little bit in that back and forth in
there
the purple is the Delta scalper cells
the blues are Delta scalper by so again
it's you know will there be an overlap
once in a while perhaps but
um
not that often okay
activity has asked sort of the same
question does it play nice with other
indicators you have on the chart
yeah I mean you can see it will work
with other indicators say I just want
you know something completely different
I mean I don't know uh
oh this is throwing Bollinger Bands I
guess
okay I'll just leave the default up
there
okay uh if you could see the bands are
on there it's fine no problem Delta
scalpers coming in shortly
still calculating because it's got tick
replay on honestly if I had
disabled right if I take off
built a scalper
you know just throw a bunch
let me let me do something first I'll
take off to replay
okay so you can see there so there's
Bollinger Bands I could remove Delta
scalper I don't need that
um
you know I don't know I could throw a
bunch of stuff on here
all right so you know you can see it's
still giving you the signals so if you
want to combine it with you know any
other indicator that you have
you can
uh Chris had asked the signals to take
an entry yeah I think you know if you're
using the signals I think it's best to
use them if you're a shorter term Trader
if you're more of a swing Trader you
know trading on a 15-minute chart Etc
um
then you'd probably want to use you
probably don't need them you just I I
would more rely on the zones
um does it work with mnq
NQ yeah it does
um
right this is mnq
NQ
okay between Q here the alignment q and
Q is going to be basically the same
signals And Trades very similar let me
just clean up this other stuff off my
chart
okay uh
let me see here
oh Manny the magenta colors
all right again it comes down to Colors
because there's two types of signals
right there's
type one
type 2 right by type 1 cell type 1 by
type 2 cell type 2.
by type 1 is green and red
by type 2
is cyan cell type 2 is magenta so it's
just to differentiate and if you want
keep them both the same color you can I
just
you know we had them separate because
originally when we were testing them we
just kept them separate I mean I I could
have lumped them in there together as
all the same just keep type 1 and type
two
on the back end you guys would never
know the difference and just put it in
there but you know it's just an option
um I you know because I know some people
they like to sort of optimize for a
market and
you know on some markets you know maybe
you you find that type one
or type 2 works better than type 1 on a
certain Market on a certain chart type
okay
does the zones follow traditional bar
Gap price action or something more
specific in the order flow well
that's a good question because it does
well obviously it starts at that price
pattern okay that's like the beginning
and then what it's doing is it's reading
some of the stuff that's taking place in
here right on the footprint
so
while it does rely on what you're
looking at you know it starts as a basis
for this you know with for example right
this is why
you know you don't see a signal coming
in off of this Gap here right because
you know off the original signal it's
going to be you know bar one bar two bar
three where you have this Gap in here
but it's not giving you a buy signal
okay just because it's not following
what we're looking for
in the order flow taking place in here
that's going to give us a decent signal
people say well it didn't go up yeah I
mean it did go up and just eventually
melted down and along the way you know
you're sort of seeing other you know Gap
here you know which sort of Trades back
up through
Etc you know so we've sort of gone
through the different scenarios and what
we like to look for because you know you
can say well there's a gap here right
you got bar one bar two bar three
okay then it did go up then it just came
right back down and would have stopped
you out so there's certain things that
we we look for in there Juan Does it
include filters
um
not really no um you know we try to keep
it simple you know because you don't
want to be filtering stuff out we do
have this pair up
which I don't want to say is necessarily
A filter but you know for example here
uh if you can see it
there's it's just going to give you
maybe an extra one or two trades a day
it's just reading something you know
where it's sort of you know pairing
something up in the order flow
um but
it was one you know this was should I
take that piece out or not we just have
it in there does this work on nine
non-time charts like Rinko well
you know it'll work on charts like
whoops
um
I don't like the
wrinkle that's on here the ninjatrader
one there's a lot of good better wrinkle
charts out there
I don't think it's going to show up on
here I mean I could be wrong
oh it does
um this is the the ninja Trader wrinkle
chart
but I'm not a big fan of it
um I just find there's other charts out
there you know from
other vendors like the uni renko type
charts I think are are more useful than
this ninjatrader one I mean it looks
beautiful on this but I I don't use that
one
um
you know the who is it Pablo's got one
he's got a nice free one from the
indicator store you can go to his
website
theindicatorstore.com and download it
just put it in your cart you got to go
through like you're buying it but it's
probably zeros out at the end
um High kanashi charts
let's give it a second here ninja
Traders acting up on me okay
um
okay I got both on here you see on this
hike and Ashley chart it's only showing
type two
magenta and cyan so there's the magenta
signal there a couple cyan cyan cyan
um
and it's probably based off of how the
bars formed on a hikanashi chart more
than anything else
obviously on a footprint chart it'll
work
um
our chart or the charts they got on here
there's a lot of there's you know I
showed you
volume range time tick works I can
actually
renko
point and figure I don't like the point
and figure that's provided by
ninjatrader
um
I don't even know if it would work on
there
not really I mean I see a magenta Zone
here I think that's all you're going to
see
oh not on the point figure but all the
other chart types you know so for
example
um
volume I don't know 1000 volume
all right this is 1000 volume on the NQ
okay so it does work on those non-time
charts
in this yeah okay I'll send you a
special link
um for that yes I did see your email
um this morning yesterday I wasn't
really answering emails because it's
Saturday Saturdays I'm just flat out
busy with uh kids activities but uh you
know I just haven't gotten to your email
are there exit signals um binket had
asked well if you're using zones right
these can be potential targets if you're
long or short if you're long because you
know at the end of the day a zone is
being drawn out is an area where the
market can stop that's one of the
reasons why we use these zones because
it could stop and reverse right see stop
and reverse stop and reverse stop and
reverse
obviously stop in Reverse here this
little tiny one here stop in reverse
um
Steve can you try volume base okay well
this is volume base 1000 volume on NQ
okay
um
Anthony asks what's the trigger in the
order flow that generates the signal
plus a couple things right obviously
there's imbalances there's gonna be
volume and point of control
uh Jared yeah I'm going to be making a
video on markers with this but it should
not be a problem
uh Stephen asks how does it compare with
the order flow pulse well it reads
completely different things
um then the pulse together
um
some pulse
what do I got here NQ
you know just really basic pulse
hung bars
this what colors
it's going to be blue and red cell
signals I wish that there was a like a
good orange color here it was not really
they're orange on ninja
Trader looks like uh still looks like
red to me
um but we'll see here oh I don't have
tick replay on
but again you know Paul's reads
something completely different in the
order flow
but does that mean that signals will not
overlap no you still might see some
overlapping
um
like the blue
here's
pulse
I don't see any cells
that's charged
back here
bye so it's mixed in here right you got
green which is bar gaps false bar gaps
bar gaps
I should use a different color than
that orange but anyway
um
again it reads different things uh
Dominique asked Can I show a four range
Ultra Bond chart sure
um let's take off this pulse
and switch this to ultra bonds
let me get to a or range chart
open this up
and that's Friday you know with ultra
bonds
it could also use tick based charts with
ultra bonds 50 or 100 take charts is
nice on Ultra bonds
this is a 50 tick chart or no sorry a
100 tick chart on Ultra bonds right
that's Friday
this is the day before
I mean it's just a different way of
looking at the market but um ultrabond
or ranges so we're getting back to your
question
that's what it looks like
and again maybe if you want to turn off
the zones
just to clean it up a bit again just
change the opacity back to zero
and just to see the signals
you know if when your bars sort of
overlap like this like these candles
you just go in here you change this bar
with to a different number
it's a smaller number
right so you can see they're not
overlapping
so you know the day before right this
was Friday kind of a muted trading
session basically we're trading 15 down
to uh 26 but the day before you had much
more movement
you know so we'll move up we'll move
down we'll move up move down move up
move down move up move down
um let's go through some more questions
here I don't want to keep you guys on
all morning it's Sunday so uh let's take
a look
okay Robin
um
Robin
yeah I'll get that sorted out Robin
can you show Gopi asks um
I'm trying to understand this
can you show Delta for the bar Gap zones
uh
uh I don't think I really
okay let me see here that was a simple
way to do it
um just bear with me here
I could do
is
this
I mean generally speaking you know when
the market is you know you're seeing
sell signals come in right you're going
to normally see
negative Delta these are just Delta
candles if you will right uh
Delta in the bar right I could put the
price of the number up there but it's
the same thing
okay so you can see
the positive Delta coming in here
because remember right if you have the
actual cell signal
it may have started one bar earlier
because it's also looking at the
complementary order flow coming in
uh let me see here Brandon asks
just writing on some of these questions
here
um because Ethan asks uh Delta scope
okay
Ethan I see a question about the delta
scalper
it's not related to this but I'll
address that
afterwards same with you Robin and Enos
um Brandon asks
he says here's the reason what's the
secret logic behind this
reason I ask is that right now should be
just seems it's an indicator as blindly
followed reducing subjectivity that is
should be a priority perhaps this is
getting too close to secret sauce with
that said you think it's always been one
you explain the reasoning why
okay okay well without getting into sort
of the mechanics of it right
when you have a gap
you do want to pay attention to how the
order flow is appearing in that bar
okay because there's really two steps to
it right because it's one thing to say
you know because I see a lot of people
saying oh you know you have a gap
right between say this bar and this bar
but what's taking place in these bars in
the order flow
right you have Supply coming in
what's the aggressive selling looking
like
how is volume being distributed
okay just like here this bar you know
you technically you have a gap between
this this and this right right in here
but what's happening in the order Flow
In These Bars to me isn't just isn't
good enough right the market came right
back up through that Gap
right because the Gap is taking place
right here and you can see a big burst
coming up right through the other side
of that Gap
um you know so you want to be paying
attention to how this bar this bar this
bar
the instance it's a buy right obviously
actual imbalances
you want to see demand coming in
and you want to see volume reacting
accordingly
uh Robin asks um
yeah it doesn't need tick replay to work
so if combined with an indicator
no it won't change anything right so the
signs will be the same the signals the
zones all that will be the same whether
you're using the tick replay or not
James Janelle says I use unirko and Enzo
renko not NT yeah
um
yeah it should be fine with the uni
wrinkle chart I know I got uni wrinkle
on a different PC
um so I can't show you on this one
uh Timothy asks is all price action
contained in the process of I guess you
meant to say sequence alternative and
iteration
I'm not sure
of your question there but
it's not just price action it's also
what's taking place
in the actual order flow over that
period
Dominica did show the four range chart
um like please
David asks I got
a bundle you know
I
do run sales
throughout the year
or it's like you know between 25 to
50 off of everything
um
I think I ran one earlier this year you
know
be on the lookout for that it will be
coming out probably next month I do have
you know just as a side David since
you're asking this question
um
you know because people always ask me
you know they see you know this is sort
of unrelated to it but um
right they see a lot of stuff in here
all right that I got and some of these
things I've released some I haven't
things like pressure
um imbalancer Etc
um I've even got some
that's like
um there's initiative Traders
responsive Traders
um
maybe like within the next month or so
you may see an email from me about a
bundle sort of My Vault things that I
haven't released but I'll just shoot
them out in one big package
down the line problem is
you know
creating the user guide all that stuff
takes time
um but anyway let's go through some more
questions will it work on higher time
frames such as 30 minutes one hour to
get better
strong zones to trade from well
you know I showed you 15 minutes 30
minute charge let me just uh
draw the zones on again it's going to
depend on your Market as well
um make this 30.
let me take this Delta off here
this is a 30 minute
ultrabond chart
okay so you see a Zone here a Zone here
Zone here
obviously this one here
um
it's just the last few days I don't know
about one hour I've been looked on one
hour chart
you know this is the one hour
um you know maybe if you're looking at
something that trades you know even the
bonds this is ultra bonds
um you know something like a currency
that trades you know literally around
the clock this is a one hour chart
you know you trade in the zone stops you
out this one stops you out this one
comes right back up to that Zone by a
couple thicks but again you're trading
that through a number
um it's nice to see this but in all
honesty I I wouldn't
I'm not sure I'd be looking to
drop in a limit order in here you know
when
what was that PPI on this was Thursday
right BPI came out Thursday
um you know if that's something that I
would do
I know a lot of people say well look at
that you could have sold it there and
had that big move but again you know I'm
not looking to trade around uh
big number like that but again this is
down to a 30 minute chart
so again it really depends
um Denise asked yeah we do have a
trading guide I don't provide
recommended settings because there's not
a lot of settings to
that you're going to be adjusting
we're going to come down to your
um
you know you
chart type
right so you know
three minute chart I don't know I don't
you look at a three minute chart but I'm
sure there's people out there that do
use a three minute chart
okay this is what it looks like on a
three minute chart
um
you know maybe some people use an eight
range chart this is what it looks like
because there's not the settings don't
need to be
adjusted you just really are you
deciding is you're using type one type
two are using both of them right you say
I got everything on both show signal so
you can see the triangles and the pair
up that's it
if I had just type 1
okay let's type one
so it's pretty simple
NK uh asks can you talk a little bit
about how this indicator Works yet I
just did
um
when will this be launched for go
charting
I'm not I'm not sure because we got our
launch of the overflows Trader coming
out
um
soon
just Abraham thank you
um
Brandon asks uh thank you your
explanation put some logic behind it as
an aside recent video you did in regards
to aggressive buyers aggressive sellers
passive incredibly helpful
um
yeah you know that's uh
I'm glad you're watching my YouTube
videos it's
it's a simple thing right the concept of
aggressive buyers aggressive sellers it
gets overlooked a lot
um everyone thinks that the market you
know buyers and sellers are always the
same but again it's sort of digress a
little bit
um
when you're looking at
order flow
right you always want to be
sort of identifying how the trading is
taking place I mean obviously the
Market's going to go up on aggressive
buying but stronger moves up are going
to be followed not only with aggressive
buying but
supportive buying you know passive bids
coming in I mean perfect example is this
move right here right we're going up
okay yeah you see the aggressive buying
coming in
and what you see in this bar 415 436
strong bids how do I know these are
strong well compare them to what's
taking place on the offer
heaviest volume on the offer is 408.
the next one is 307 so the strongest
bids are coming in here
just as down here right we make this new
low
trades 87 right because remember this
Market open spark close this Market open
up went down lower starts reversing and
as you're reversing yeah people are
buying the offers but you got a strong
bid in here 936.
so you got some support of buying coming
in
um
all right just a few more questions here
then we're done
um
is the triangle marker down on the close
of the bar on which it appears it should
appear as soon as the conditions are met
okay
this time of day make a trade do you
does time of day you trade make a
difference
um
no I don't think so because you know
let's go back to a time-based chart here
it's a little bit easier to see time of
day
um Jared yeah it doesn't uh it should
appear as soon with the triangle as soon
as the conditions are met the Zone has
got to sort of wait for the bar to close
before for confirmation but the
triangles as soon as the conditions
hit
so like for example right this is Euro
currency this is at one in the morning
Chicago time right because I'm in
Chicago so I'm like PC is set to Chicago
time right it's giving you the triangle
there right to go up if I was to
sort of scrunch it down you know that
that sort of that Asian time to me is
kind of a dead zone sort of that time
from the reopen until about
um
you know seven eight o'clock to me
that's like the the dead zone of trading
but yeah you can see some signals here
you know I stopped out here stopped out
there Friday
um you know but other markets are a bit
more active you know that there's the
the fascinating thing about the markets
is there are
you know for example okay so this is
Euro currency right what's the most
active times in Euro currency well
obviously it's a euro currency so in
Europe is open
yeah you're gonna get more movement
but then obviously during the U.S
session during the Asian session it's a
lot quieter if you're looking at the
Asian session you know trade uh Aussie
dollars 6A I haven't looked at Aussie
dollars with this but let's take a look
what am I on I'm on uh
one minute chart
right this is during the Aussie session
on Friday right
7 P.M Chicago time nice movements
right that was Friday
um
the day before
all right here there's no signal but you
had that zone being drawn out where the
market came right back to that zone and
rallied but in here you're getting you
know we had some stuff coming out in
Asia at that time here but after it came
out nice move down
but in general generally speaking no you
know I think this is a indicator you
could use around the
time
um Timothy asks
is the triangle basically which no the
triangle is just this the signal of the
plot
right if I were to
let me turn off the zones when I talk
about the triangle
okay you see nothing on the chart
triangle is the signal right that's
under the pots down here
triangle up for buy signals triangle
down for the cell signal right now you
see them
um
does the marker draw and redraw
no it just draws
I'm gonna redraw um Bob asks is your
Zone tool coded as objects or plots
I'm not sure Bob that's one I'd have to
ask the programmer on on how he did it
well I'll make a note of that
foreign
objects
all right guys I'll end it there for
today I don't want to keep you guys on
all morning
um for some of you guys all evening so
again you know if you are interested in
this indicator
just really quick
um
that's where you can get it right now
it's it's only in one Buck net Buck 97
197.
um you know so it's pretty decent
price and again it'll work with any any
um
other things you have on your chart
right I showed it with a bunch of other
indicators
and again you know it I think it's just
a nice addition to have in your
chart toolbox so to speak
okay
so
thanks everyone for coming on on this
Sunday morning you know it was uh it's
always great to connect and see what
questions people have Enis Robin Ethan
um I'll take care of you guys so have a
great uh go Bears yeah hopefully Daniel
hopefully uh you know after last week's
uh debacle
um they'll get things turned around so
hopefully it'll be a good game Sorry all
right everyone
um have a great rest of your weekend
what's left of it Sunday and I'll catch
you guys uh next time bye bye